there are new allegations of racist
sexist and homophobic behavior against
two long-time cbs executives
who oversee the network's local tv
stations don champion a former freelance
reporter at our new york station wcvs tv
said in a facebook post that he was
bullied and discriminated against
for being a gay black man it follows
allegations of sexism and racism by
peter dunn and david friend at the cbs
station in philadelphia
first reported by the los angeles times
our national correspondent
arika duncan spoke to don champion about
experiencing what he calls
blatant bigotry my agent warned me
be careful you're gay black and a man
don champion says he was warned of
problems at wcbs tv in new york
before he started his job as a freelance
reporter in 2013.
you know i i i can't
i can't say enough how much fear you
live in
when you're in this situation whether i
was able to make
rent or eat that month was dependent on
how david felt about me
i was just trying to endure it and
survive champion came forward tuesday
after the release of an l.a times report
alleging sexism and racism by cbs
executives
david friend and peter dunn who run 28
local cbs stations
what's the biggest concern in all of
this
when you look at how long they have
yielded this amount of power how many
other
lives and careers they've ruined i mean
these are two
very very powerful men in the tv news
industry
the la times report focused largely on
cbs station kyw
tv in philadelphia the article reviewed
allegations that dunn and friend
cultivated a hostile work environment
that included bullying female managers
and blocking efforts to hire and retain
black journalists
margaret cronin was news director at kyw
for nearly two years
she left in 2017. cronin says friend
her boss at the time didn't explicitly
use racist language
but she says it was implied in some
emails
i would receive that when i was trying
very hard
to hire people of color
i seem to get them rejected left and
right
and i would get emails that say he can't
talk
or he can't write cronin told the times
that dunn reportedly took
aim at veteran anchor yuki washington
calling him
just a jive guy do you think peter dunn
and david friend are racist you don't
feel comfortable coming out and
answering that
do you think they should be fired i
believe they should no longer be
running the cbs television station
division what about the dozens of people
who've been impacted
by decisions made at the very top who
will never get
a chance to be yuki my heart goes out to
them
last night an emotional washington who
has been at kyw
more than 30 years thanked his
supporters my mom told me as a kid
that there is strength in numbers it's
still true we all have the power to
create change and we can do it
together cbs internally investigated
dunn in 2019
in a statement to the la times the
company said senior management at the
time addressed the situation with him
but had not had new complaints since
then earlier this week cbs announced
dunn and friend are on leave pending a
new
third party investigation adding cbs is
committed to a diverse
inclusive and respectful workplace in a
new statement tuesday the company said
all concerns presented will be
considered in the new investigation
when you hear of people now in powerful
positions at cbs saying we are
about diversity we respect everyone what
do you make of that
i have watched from the outside of the
changes at the network level
and i i certainly applaud that uh but
everyone in the in the tv business knows
that
from the local news level this was a
reckoning that needed to happen
friend previously told the la times that
he has a strong
track record when it comes to hiring
supporting and placing women and people
of color in
important roles and he also went on to
tell cbs news that champions accusations
are based on nothing but conjecture
friend offered champion of staff
job as a reporter and cb at cbs in 2019
which
champion did acknowledge friends said
his critiques of mr champion were always
based
on performance and had nothing to do
with race
gender or sexual orientation meanwhile
dunn's attorney tells cbs news that dunn
is confident
that he has always acted properly and
any investigation he says
will confirm this jerica
it's important as don said in your
reporting that this comes to light and
i'm so happy that it is uh and i saw the
outpouring of love for yuki
on social media yesterday you know just
once again cementing that he's not just
a hero to many in philly but all over
this country how's don doing
yeah he he really he really is uh vlad
and i just want to mention that because
i worked with yuki for several years at
that station
uh as for don you know he said that this
was a trigger for him and this is why he
decided to speak out
seeing that la times article and for him
reminiscing back to what he went through
he said made him want to
to call attention to his experience yeah
both yuki and don excellent reporters
thank you very much eureka as always we
appreciate it